envie de discuter avec lui j'ai plein de
choses à lui dire amat et je suis très
très heureux de le voir ces voix là
c'est vraiment un ami voilà ce qui t'es
parti voilà de mes amis dans le métier
et je suis très heureux qu'il soit avec
nous ce lundi on a plein de choses à
voir avec lui et bien sûr on terminera
par un mode arcade avec le débrief des
l'attendait et dieu sait qu'on va faire
20 minutes là dessus voilà ce héros
tracas c'est pas mma voilà je vous le
dis qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de dar k dont une disparition vous avez
vu que le chien de mariah carey a
disparu samedi soir quand les nrj music
tour
voilà les nrj music awards laisser ça me
fait ça m'a fait de la peine
les chéris j'aurais juste deux petites
choses il ya beaucoup de gens qui me
demandent des nouvelles de jean mi bon
j'ai envie d'amour sachez que jean mimi
il est fatigué il est malade mon jour me
voilà on va pas se mentir on va le dire
il alla qu'ovide c'est pas une honte un
jour me d'amour la deuxième fois
exactement
fatigué il a eu là pour la douzième fois
mon ami il est très fatigué j'ai eu des
nouvelles de lu par sms encore
aujourd'hui
dès qu'il ira mieux bien sûr il
reviendra parmi nous mais l'a pour
l'instant il est fatigué notre vie
d'avant perdu 28 fort à lui parce qu'on
la donne jean denis et on lui fait
d'énormes vite et si vous trouvez les
cherry qui vous pouvez lui laisser un
petit message sur les réseaux traduit
fera extrêmement plaisir parce que vous
lui manquer
sachez le et ça lui fera très plaisir à
jean mi qui est un garçon qui a un coeur
énorme